We have a voicemail number that you can call
whenever you please.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here is a very interesting voicemail weighing
in about Donald Trump's weaponization of soup,
which we covered yesterday.
Take a listen to this.
Hey, David.
I just want to call in because I thought of
a little theory that I want to get your thoughts
on.
Yeah.
So as you know, like Trump has recently begun,
talks of, like the weaponization of Sue and
bagging can form.
Right.
And I think that might just be why he was
so concerned about the cupboards being there
when I got into office.
Right.
Does.
You know, like we were out of bullets.
The cupboards were bare, like we were completely
defenseless, basically.
Yeah, exactly.
Like, no no cans.
I would I would wager.
No.
No bags of soup.
Yeah.
This is interesting.
You know, Donald Trump has been using this
phrase that when he took over from Barack
Obama, the cupboards were bare.
And it's weird to talk about cupboards, but
where do people keep cans of soup?
They typically keep them in cupboards.
And maybe what Donald Trump meant was that
soup cans, which he now has made clear he
considers weapons in that weird rant yesterday,
the cupboard had no cans of soup.
That is absolutely crazy.
But it makes about as much sense as everything
else that Donald Trump says.
So I'm glad you're thinking to it.
To our viewer who called.
Then we have a great bonus show for you today.
Nancy Pelosi has handed Trump a gift.
And I'm going to tell you what that is.
Hoboken is going to be suing fossil fuel companies
over flooding, saying it is a climate change
issue.
And I am going to give you the latest updates
on the census.
I had some interactions recently with census
workers, safe ones wearing masks, of course.
All of those stories and more on the bonus
show get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at Join Patman dot com.